What currently works?
Well actually, let's talk a little
bit about what used to work, well,
still does, what worked a while ago,
and what's working now.
So what worked sort of say yesterday?
Okay.
Yesterday being proverbially not today.
All right, so
things like reading license plates,
well that's pretty easy
because it's a fixed font.
Zip codes, numbers on checks,
those are getting much better, and
handwritten recognition of
digits has gotten pretty good.
Fingerprint recognition.
The analysis of those patterns,
because the patterns share certain
types of characteristics, and
we could find those characteristics.
Face detection, but you'll notice that
here the thing knows who I am, but
it hasn't yet figured out who Megan is.
Right?
Today we do recognition.
By the way you know,
these days typically when you pop-up or
put an image let's say on to Facebook or
some other thing, it'll suggest you
the names of the people that are there.
And that means that it's
found the faces, and
it's also recognized who they are.
Now, it doesn't searches
database of everybody,
it only searches your friends.
Right?
So it doesn't have to try to recognize
this as anybody on the planet, just
the five friends that I happen to have.
Right?
So then you might ask, well, how does
it know the picture of those friends?
Well, other people have
tagged Megan in images.
Every time you tag an image with a face,
person's name,
you're actually telling Google, or
whoever, or Facebook, or whoever you're
doing, how to recognize that person.
So without meaning, making it sound
nefarious, it is the case that every
time you tag somebody else in a picture,
you're making it that much easier for
computers to find that
person in other images.
You are teaching.
You are not tagging, you are teaching
the system what Megan looks like.
So just, just,
just think about that every time
you identify people in an image.
We've actually talked
about sift features and
using the location of sift features
to recognize objects and, you know,
sort of flat textured things
like the book covers.
All right.
Now what just happened?
This is GoogleNet 2014,
which was part of a competition.
And you can see here that
given this image, okay,
it labels the monitor, the bookshelf.
It even labels this dom,
this, it says domestic cat.
And it looks to me like this
cat is jumping in the air, so
that's pretty cool.
What makes this picture hard, of course
is the very intense color variation.
So it was able to find, just basically
through the color and texture,
cause that's the only
thing that's there,
the fact that there were oranges and
bananas there.
So this is a pretty intriguing result,
and then here's a result that,
calls into question
the importance of context.
And maybe what it means is
that context doesn't matter
when things are very clear.
All right?
So I love this picture.
I'm not sure you can read this, but
it says hat with wide brim on the top,
and it says dog on the bottom.
Now, I don't know how many pictures
there are of dogs with hats and
wide brims wearing them.
What scares me is,
there might be tens of thousands,
because people have way too much
time on their hands or something.
I don't know.
But, it is an impressive result that it
was able to recognize the hat on top of
the dog, which you have to believe
is not a likely position for a hat.